a seemingly throwaway line from avengers
endgame got some comic fans attention as
it just may have teased the arrival at
the classic Marvel hero for phase 4 of
the MCU or on the other hand maybe
hasn't such as the state of studies at
Marvel Cinematic Universe 'ti better
known as MCU of course be advised that
major spoilers for endgame follow during
his mission to secure more Pym particles
at the shield base in 1970 Steve Rogers
finds himself in the office of director
Peggy Carter he's taken aback by his
proximity to his long-lost flame and the
picture of him lovingly displayed on her
desk
and let's be honest so was the audience
it's a poignant heartstring tugging
moment so it's pretty easy to miss what
Peggy seems to be saying as Rogers gazes
at her through the office window
according to one intrepid reddit poster
who claims to have seen the flick with a
closed captioning device Carter says
Braddock hasn't checked in I'm not a
meteorologist and it's not lightning now
we haven't been able to directly confirm
that this is the dialogue she speaks and
you probably know to take the average
reddit post with a grain of salt in
terms of its overall reliability
additionally Carter delivers of dialogue
washes in another room so the line
itself was pretty hard to hear without
the aid of a closed captioning device
but if the post is accurate and Carter
does mention Braddock it could very well
be referring to a classic Marvel
character who has yet to show up in the
MCU Brian Braddock better known as a
super-powered Captain Britain making his
first appearance in captain britain
issued number one in 1976 brian product
was a graduate of london's thames
university working as a physicist on an
experiment involving antimatter
particles under dr. hugo travis when a
villain descended on the facility to
steal the research Braddock fled to get
help but crashed his motorcycle and
sustained what would have been fatal
injuries and that's when his story took
a turn for the weird on the verge of
death of Braddock was discovered by none
other than Merlin the legendary wizard
of English folklore sensing products
heroic hearts Merlin gave him a choice
of two objects the sword of might or the
amulet of Rights not believing himself
to have the heart of a warrior
Braddock chose the amulet and upon
receiving it he was transformed into
Captain Britain with his own snazzy
costume and a bunch of superpowers like
super strength super endurance and
flight among others Captain Britain
isn't the only prominent hero named
Braddock in Marvel Comics law the other
is his twin sister Beth
Braddock who eventually became the
superhero known as Psylocke she showed
up in 20th Century Fox's x-men
apocalypse in 2016
played by Olivia Munn but Captain
Britain just seemed like a more likely
candidate for a future appearance in the
MCU for a few reasons for starters a
Cylons own comic book origin story is
even more bonkers than the one we just
described for Captain Britain not only
that but psylocke status as a member of
the x-men cast of characters means it's
pretty unlikely she or any of the other
Marvel mutants will show up in the MCU
too soon since Disney's acquisition of
20th Century Fox is still so fresh more
importantly however is the fact that
Marvel Studios boss Kevin Feige has
actually admitted that he and his
colleagues have discussed bringing
Captain Britain into the MCU in 2017
during the press tour for spider-man
homecoming
Feige was asked about the potential
status of a cinematic version of Captain
Britain we have discussed it we have
discussed it there are a lot of actors
that come in and ask about that about
that part so we'll have to see could
this be the first hint that Captain
Britain is coming could that be yet
another captain being added to the MCU
or is this just one wild goose chase
based on a misheard line of dialogue
when it comes to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe all things are possible check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more loop of videos about
Avengers and game are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]